[Musique]
est-ce que la pandémie actuelle en
cacherait une autre encore plus
meurtrière réponses courtes non mais sur
le web
certains y croient dur comme fer tout
commence à la fin mars avec un cas
mortel dans ta virus recensés en chine
le tabloïd chinois global times est liée
au pouvoir central tweet la nouvelle
accompagnée d'une photo d'une personne
en train de subir un test de dépistage
de la coved 19 sans fournir énormément
de détails au delà de ce simple tweet a
déclenché une vague d'inquiétude et de
désinformation faut dire que lanta virus
à un taux de mortalité très élevé aux
alentours de 38 % avec des symptômes
comme l'essoufflement et des difficultés
respiratoires graves
de nombreuses personnes ont alors
commencé à établir des liens entre lanta
virus et le nouveau corps à des virus à
l'origine de la coved 19 alimentant
évidemment vous l'aurez deviné des
craintes d'une pandémie additionnel
cette vidéo visionnée plus de 260 mille
fois prétend que ce virus le hantavirus
est le cousin de celui au centre de la
crise mondiale actuelle
mais comme le note mon collègue nicolas
de rosa qui a écrit un article à ce
sujet l'unique manière de contracter
dans ta virus et d'entrer en contact
direct avec lui rinne les excréments ou
la salive d'un rongeur effecté la
transmission interhumaine est impossible
annulant du coup tout risque d'épidémie
selon l' agence de la santé publique du
canada
le risque d'être infecté par l'entamé
russe ici royère dans le monde est
plutôt faible
encore une fois avant de partager des
informations qui sème le doute dans
votre esprit
écrivez-nous cette proposition comme ça
allez salut
[Musique]